nice pass swing it boy baseline pull-up
got it I just love how their movement
get you another way back
he's got great touch at least
[Applause]
4228 Milken's as great vision and really
for a big guy
Paul can pass the basketball then fines
for fines for not two guys gonna
surround and just of a quick will hook
pass around
Randall Forex hit me heaven o 12 to run
never excluding the lane to yoga that's
as good a pass as you ever seen from a
bit bit Nicola yo couch this guy has
eyes in the back of his head
[Music]
that's unbelievable
[Music]
like goodness 20 years old he's going to
get better folks the other one he had
Scott this is unbelievable I think
Randolph and Gasol watch him there
watching Yogi's player there's not even
think about let's get some stuff folks
yo kids will shoot no you give it
together
watch Huggins finds it guzzling with a
garb but to buy the bag and we've
already seen that this year and then
watch this wide open three let me just
get a layup what an unselfish
to your kids the aggressive here's
mudiay put the base up pull it to that
hand away from the D in this over the
shoulder you want to distance over the
shoulder hood wrong
11 points 9 assists in 27 minutes that
was burned that was buried with the
screen of the wig sighs I just got G
wide open
Nelson's handling at the point where
he's wizard play loaded your best
passing big guy in another three
occasions
[Applause]
oh my goodness a one-hand slinger from
the yogurt stuff this are you looking
were you looking oh my goodness I mean
that's like Pete Maravich just into yo
kitch the facilitator
hello hook pass yo catch tamanna ball
yes we may have a highlight program off
of yoke I mean folks is the 7-footer I
mean you just you don't see this kind of
a building from this big of a guy
Humphries around everybody missed it
here comes your couch
yokas dump it yes Millsap here's that
play a while ago
bounce pass not look and now said he'll
be out until probably the fourth quarter
believe I said that tie to season is it
a chance the rebound
[Applause]
don't she
so game assists shame on put it back in
the region over the top in the middle
through the woods to Grandma's house
we're going
channelers and crap oh crap oh it's me
it's not the big bad woman it's me got
the youngster its first basket a night
in a hard hard cut the shoulder just
written a perfect lays out in front of
him
well Barton this is your beer is Murray
Hugo Ozzie Nelson letting it fly look
mom target is waist short the lab
upstairs took the lead here in London
[Music]
hookers got it pass another furry
[Applause]
I'll free for hanging on the rim we need
a justice said though they get the
no-look pass three we swung a little bit
but why not after our brilliant pass
like that
well he got prompt to do when you give
up and you're done do they usually let
you hang on it long range no girl
he's got 12 more late
and Nicola yo conspirators Pat's his
first triple-double of his NBA career
pass
at least a triple-double which the
playoffs possibly in possibly playing
against the Warriors in the first round
[Applause]
right that's a great pass by the big
fellow right there you read that all the
way I love his patience for a big man in
the post great pass right there three
guys on you make the teammates better
oh good screen by yoke it's just buried
that is behind the back to Chandler it
was actually over the head to Chandler
and a score moat
as sweet as it gets Nicoli okage doing
his thing Wilson Chandler and Gary
Harris doing their things coming back to
Bankers Life Fieldhouse you wanna make
those switch and everything trying to
front of the pump getting calls on the
other side this Watson quick tap just a
heads-up play that's the way you know
you're G once he knows where his
teammates hit down I look at him he's
all ready captain
that's a magic for that 16 turnover
charge to the Denver Nuggets
a lot of attention to him they got this
[Applause]
still on the help of Booker and there it
is and then whoop right behind the back
to bees one dribble finishes Nagas we're
down by 6 I could say three over Paris
you'll get you back to the good side the
back to Chandler no perfect you see no
one there paying attention the second
time he's got double to
[Music]
[Applause]
you can see what one juice one guy's
mate one guy does a good job of Laos not
just stand-in there I saw on highlights
one time Larry Bird says powering it up
no yoga jezik there's a reset on the
2000 my god my goodness
Lyle's scores where did that pass come
from I'm not sure I did
there it is an incredible dish careful
now
5 to shoot back game is confidence now
Nicole the yogurts doll to work on
deadly gonna power it up behind the back
Lyle's off the glass yes oh what a
password hey beautiful
no look behind the back pass for Nicole
e opens Bradley
account started it and then watch this
long fast he didn't even get it to the
other hand ken Duke it's trying to find
their offensive rhythm here
Nichola on the drive pass it out great
pass to Morris who knocks it in the
floppy floater flew out of bounds water
polo pass Beasley
[Music]
how about that for your kids assist and
watch his kids assist to turnover Liese
to someone minnesota fell asleep
Liggins nearly got there but third
rebound
[Applause]
he's trying to stay on this body
actually jump Victoria Craig maybe to
get back in this ball game if he does
check in this place is going to go crazy
[Applause]
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content